coupe du monde de football le premier
choc des demi finales ce soir sur france
2 à 21h à marseille le brésil affronte
les pays-bas campagne nationale pour les
dons d'organes la pénurie sérieuse en
france l'an dernier plus de 300 malades
sont morts faute d'avoir trouvé un
donneur grandes manoeuvres dans les
armées dans l'industrie militaire
redéploiement des troupes et plan social
bon giat industries opération coup de
frein sur la côte d'azur à vie au pilote
occasionnel de bateaux à moteur qui ne
respectent pas les vitesses imposées mal
à monsieur bonsoir phase finale de la
coupe du monde de football nous y sommes
il n'y aura que deux élus pour quatre
prétendants et dès ce soir nous
connaîtrons le premier ce sera le brésil
ou les pays bas qui vont s'affronter en
direct sur france 2 à partir de 21h à
marseille vous voyez l'ambiance est déjà
très chaude
le match débarrasser des hooligans qui
ont gâché le début de la fête et bien
c'est ce soir la bonne humeur la joie
dans les rues un mélange de couleurs
orange et jaune reportage laurent
frédéric bollée frédéric basque la route
a été longue mais tous les chemins
mènent à marseille pour les hollandais
faire plus de 1500 kilomètres en deux
joutes entretiendrait même plutôt la
forme le vieux port en milieu d'après
midi
pas de doute ce sont bien les oranje qui
sont arrivés les premiers
et avec eux toute une panoplie
d'accoutrement dont le moins qu'on
puisse dire est qu'il faut oser en tout
cas c'est le genre d'ambiance à propos
de laquelle il vaut mieux prendre une
certaine hauteur et je pense que nous
le brésil justement arrive seulement en
fin d'après midi c'est par train et avec
un peu de retard que la majorité des
brésiliens a fait le déplacement en type
musée dans des tgv orange une vraie
provocation mais enfin ils y sont et la
gare saint-charles n'avait peut-être
jamais connu ça les brumisateurs ne sont
pas trop après 4h30 de voyages 4h30
d'une fiesta qui augmentent à chaque
instant au déplaisir de quelques
voyageurs qui ne s'y attendait pas
c'était aussi la fête
déjà je trouve
trop brésilien je trouve trop voisinage
mais c'est aussi pour ça qu'on les aime
et que leur venue à marseille aura
mobilisé toutes les énergies
on a quand même 13 autre affrété par les
tour opérators plus quatre trains
supplémentaires tous double rame ce qui
devrait faire entre 9000 et entre 13000
personnes en fin d'après-midi le périple
s'achève les hollandais bien sûr sont
déjà au stade vélodrome depuis longtemps
les brésiliens qui arrive enfin les
jaunes
contrairement aux anges n'était pas
pressé sur place dans le stade vélodrome
laurent frédéric bollée ce que
l'ambiance est la même qu'à l'extérieur
mais oui tout à fait daniel les gens des
deux camps si j'ose dire s'installe
petit à petit à moins d'une heure manon
du coup d'envoi et pour compléter le
sujet qu'on vient de voir c'est vrai
qu'il y avait aujourd'hui dans marseille
une ambiance vraiment formidable une
vraie fat fraternité car évidemment les
supporters n'ont pas arrêté de se
croiser dans la ville et c'est vrai que
marseille qui conclut ce soir cette
coupe du monde puisque c'est le dernier
match organisé ici à marseille et bien
ça conclut donc de manière heureuse
cette phase finale de coupe du monde et
pour ne pas les citer évidemment par
rapport aux passagers anglais ça va
changer vraiment pas mal
sinon daniel juste pour vous dire qu'au
niveau un petit peu du terrain les
supporters des deux équipes en avoir
discuté avec eux pensent que le
vainqueur de ce soir sera champion du
monde alors c'est un petit peu méprisant
peut-être pour les adversaires que sont
que peuvent être et croient tous les
français mais c'est vrai que depuis les
huitièmes de finale
eh bien les hollandais et les brésiliens
ont marqué le plus de buts en tout 13
buts depuis le début de la compétition
pour le brésil 11 pour les pays bas ce
sont les deux meilleures attaques de ce
mondial
donc les supporters des deux camps la
sont d'accord l'équipe ian ce soir et le
futur champion du monde donc on verra
bien et puis dernière précision daniel
si vous le voulez bien il pleut
actuellement à marseille il ya une ondée
en ce moment faut dire qu'il a fait très
lourd toute cette journée
alors on ne sait pas trop si cela
annonce un match un petit peu qui va
sentir à défaut de la poudre la foudre
mais en tout cas il pleut pour l'instant
marseille on verra quels incidents ça
peut avoir tout à l'heure
mais si l'on à propos de ce match de ce
soir donc il oppose deux équipes qui
sans avoir le même style de jeu sont
portés toutes les deux à l'attack le
brésil compte sur sa star ronaldo entre
autres mais hollandais sur berck en
l'absence d'eau vers mars blessés la
rencontre de ce soir c'est également la
revanche de 1994 qui avait vu la
victoire des brésiliens alexandre quart
brésil pays bas
c'est le mélange des genres la rencontre
du sud et du nord
un tableau plein de couleurs une belle
affiche de football jaune comme ronaldo
l'enfant prodige du brésil à 21 ans le
gamin des faubourgs de rio est une star
internationale
plus encore le meilleur joueur du monde
si l'on en prend la fifa malgré une
prestation en demi teinte depuis le
début du mondial il reste le meneur de
jeu de la seleçao orange comme dennis
burke en verre camplong l'heure celui
que la presse des pays-bas surnomme le
mot trois pieds à 29 ans il compte 62
sélections et 36 buts en équipe
nationale bertand c'est l'homme
providentiel le bon génie de l'équipe
néerlandaise
brésil pays bas sont des jeunes des
histoires 1974 une autre époque
la coupe du monde se déroule en
allemagne le brésil joue en bleu est le
nouveau roi de football et néerlandais
il s'appellerait en créer le brésil
battu 2 à 0 et éliminé en demi finale
vingt ans après dallas états unis brésil
pays bas c'est un quart de finale
la seleçao couleur bleue tient sa
revanche et illumine les pays bas 3 à 2
cette année là les brésiliens sur un
champion du monde
ces jours ci les brésiliens ont quitté
leur résidence doré d'ozoir la ferrière
pour le sud de la france
ils se sont entraînés une dernière fois
dans un stade de toulon côté néerlandais
c'est à aix en provence france entraîne
une préparation physique dans la
décontraction sous les yeux de quelques
supporters fidèle d'entre les fidèles
blessé au cours de l'entraînement
bogaert ne jouera pas ce soir mais
soyons en sûr il y aura de belles
actions sur le terrain et de belle image
pour l'album souvenir du mondial 98 au
brésil dans les grandes circonstances
comme celles d'aujourd'hui c'est
véritablement tout un pays qui
s'arrêtent pour s'adonner à sa passion
le football
à rio il sera 16 heures lorsque le coup
d'envoi sera donné sur place christophe
duchiron français à rio
c'est l'hiver et c'est l'enfer dehors il
n'avait que 30 degrés l'eau est à 20
c'est un bon point
il n'y a pas beaucoup de baigneurs deux
amoureux s'embrassent un rameur passes
et trois jeunes s'amusent avec un ballon
autrement dit à la plage
le carioca n'annonce pas encore la
couleur mais en ville c'est différent
footix à rio on pourrait l'appeler le
boulevard de la coupe du monde
ou mieux encore la vis du brésil avec
aux fenêtres des immeubles beaucoup de
vert et de jaune du bleu et un peu de
blanc les couleurs du drapeau ça n'est
pas encore la fièvre mais la température
monte doucement
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'en matière de pronostics l'homme de
rillieux de doute de rien pour la finale
france brésil on va gagner 2 à 0 le
brésil cinq fois champion aujourd'hui
victoire 3-1 la finale savez de france
brésil et le brésil va gagner 2 1
c'est le brésil qui va être champion et
kopstal gagnerait beaucoup d'argent
qu'il ait plus de 77 ans ou moins de
sept mois vous l'aurez compris l'homme
de rio ne parle même pas de la demi
finale contre les pays-bas unis si un
adversaire fantôme nous rappellerons
donc gentiment à nos amis brésiliens
il ne faut pas vendre le maillot du
joueur hollandais avant de l'avoir
battue et tous brésiliens qui se
respecte sait bien que le dieu du
football et par contient prix
aussi capricieux que la vague sur la
plage et passe tout sur son passage
sur le papier donc les brésiliens sont
toujours favoris mais les hollandais ne
sont pas de simples outsiders amsterdam
c'est toute une population qui espère
dans la victoire des maillots orange
dans une ambiance plutôt tranquille
sébastien guibert dominique bonnet ce
sont les instructions de la police
tous les bars de la place liedts eu un
stade à doivent ranger les tables et les
chaises de leurs terrasses simple mesure
de prudence moyens aussi d'accueillir
ici davantage de spectateurs car tout à
l'heure la place sera bondé devant les
écrans personne ne veut rater la
demi-finale
ouais je pense que les pays bas vont
gagner qu'ils vont très bien joué les
cafetiers et serveurs se prépare donc
pour le grand rendez la soirée sera
chargé au moins jusqu'au coup de sifflet
final
un chiffre à la paroisse c'est important
ouais aussi pour l'ambiance c'est
l'équipe r c'est clair le bas se lit
draps complètement cinq minutes
les supporters hollandais suivront donc
le match avec quel esprit quelques
douloureux sourire deux finales perdues
en 74 et 78 et un doute
l'équipe ce soir sera t-elle enfin à la
hauteur certains sont pourtant sûrs de
passer quoi qu'il arrive une bonne
soirée
moi je suis marié à une brésilienne
alors à lire à regarder le match dans un
bar brésilien et moi j'irai dans un bar
hollandais ouais je préfère que le
brésil gagne mais ce sont les pays bas
ce sera très bien pour moi aussi aucun
problème pour les supporters hollandais
le match de ce soir n'est pas uniquement
l'occasion rêvé d'accéder pour la
troisième fois de leur histoire en
finale d'une coupe du monde le match
contre le brésil
eidos est un moyen de démontrer qu'un
pays de 15 millions d'habitants
peut-être aussi une grande nation de
football voilà je n'oublie pas l'équipe
de france nous y reviendrons tout à
l'heure on encore 24 heures devant nous
l'an dernier en france près de 300
personnes sont mortes faute d'avoir pu
subir une transplantation d'organes
c'est pour cette raison qu'une campagne
nationale sur les dons d'organes est
lancée aujourd'hui dans toute la france
cette campagne coïncide avec la mise en
service d'un registre des refus
chaque personne refusant l'idée de
léguer une partie de son corps à la
science pourra s'y inscrire ainsi pour
les autres il pourra être considéré
qu'ils sont d'accord pour un prélèvement
éventuelle d'une marine est patrick
desmure maurice gaillard 67 ans jour
après jour ils espèrent une
transplantation cardiaque
seul un don d'organe peut le sauver
ouais j'ai un certain la rue aujourd'hui
il ya beaucoup de jeunes le plus jeune
que moi et qui demandent qu'à vivre la
personne quand elle est décédée alors
même pas son coeur avec elle elle va pas
le mettre en bourse soit elle met à la
banque s'est terminé alors bien sûr la
religion des fois fait que on donne pas
une partie de son corps mais il faut
réfléchir et 5300 français attendent un
organe 320 sont morts l'an dernier faute
de greffe en théorie les médecins
peuvent prélever sur un mourant sauf si
celui ci a fait auparavant connaître son
opposition par écrit ou à sa famille en
réalité cette démarche est si rare que
les proches dans l'incertitude optent
généralement pour le refus des médecins
respectent cette décision c'est pour
inciter les citoyens se déterminer que
dans toutes les pharmacies de france est
exposée un document deux parties
premièrement une carte qui une fois
signée autorise prélèvements
deuxièmement un formulaire lui aussi
assigné qui interdit que l'on touche au
corps personnellement comme ça
je suis pas tellement pour enfin il faut
réfléchir infections à prendre au niveau
de la famille haut niveau dont les
décisions positives iront au fichier des
donneurs les refus dans un registre
informatique consultables au moment du
décès pour tous les autres ce sera à la
famille de décider on viens de
l'entendre
chez ce malade qui vient de parler en
france comme ailleurs le don d'organes
n'est pas une chose banale lien entre
des considérations religieuses
familiales morale qui pèse lourd dans la
décision
jean bernard schmidt vincent bouffard au
delà de la mort il ya parfois la vie
lorsque les médecins ont constaté la
mort cérébrale et que le maintien en
activité d'un cornée qu'artificielle se
pose alors la question du prélèvement
d'organes un acte qui peut permettre de
sauver un autre malade ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il faut que chaque corps
deviennent propriété des médecins il
faut que ça passe par une démarche
personnelle pour respecter ce caractère
humain du corps
même après l'amour le père verspieren
réfléchit depuis longtemps à ces
questions d'éthique au sein de l'église
ces problèmes moraux chantal biquotidien
aussi les affronter tous les jours elles
répondent à la détresse des familles
soudainement en deuil et à leurs
questions sur les dons d'organes
venez patients en attente ne nous
servent jamais d'arguments je ne pas
dire à une famille on est une jeune
fille qui meurt on hépatite fulminante
dans le service d'à côté il faut
absolument vous donniez vous rendez
compte on sait pas bien si jamais on
n'est jamais là pour culpabiliser
écouter avant de proposer le prélèvement
accompagner les proches
après cette décision si difficile à
prendre et surtout expliquer comment
tout cela se passe touche la fibre
intime des familles la fibre sensible
les familles je crois qu'il faut pas la
banaliser du tout il faut simplement
expliqué que ce qui est fait est fait
dans la clarté que les organes qui sont
prélevés sont pour des gens qui en ont
besoin
nouveau mois demain on ne sait pas ce
qu'il advient de réserve je pense que
cette démarche là qu'il faut ferrer
parler du don d'organes c'est
implicitement parler de la mort un sujet
tabou que l'on aborde rarement avant du
ciel message à faire passer c'est que
chacun s'exprime là où il est et
notamment devant sa famille cela
facilitera beaucoup la tâche de la
famille et cela supprimera beaucoup de
souffrance que la personne et didon ou
qu'elle ait dit oui
aujourd'hui rares sont ceux qui
s'opposent systématiquement au
prélèvement d'organes mais ceux qui se
prononcent clairement de leur vivant
sont aussi rares plusieurs associations
de victimes du sang contaminé s'adresse
directement au ministre de la justice
pour récuser les trois magistrats qui
composent la cour de justice de la
république doit prochainement dire si
oui ou non les trois ministres laurent
fabius georgina dufoix edmond hervé sont
disculpés dans cette affaire les
associations estiment que ces trois
magistrats ne sont pas forcément
objectif dans la mesure où ils siègent
déjà au sein de la chambre criminelle de
la cour de cassation qui s'est prononcée
elle pour un abandon des poursuites
dominique verdeilhan jean jacques bracq
leurs derniers espoirs
elisabeth guigou l'association des
transfusés se tourner vers le garde des
sceaux
mais victime et avocats ne dépasseront
pas la porte du ministère de la justice
dans un courrier remis à l'entrée il
explique au ministre ce qui les révolte
ce qui les scandalisent jeudi dernier la
cour de cassation donne sa définition de
l'empoisonnement de magistrats sont
présents à l'audience les avocats ont
disséqué la décision 26 magistrats en
délibéré parmi eux les trois juges qui
appartiennent à la cour de justice
trois juges qui vont se baser sur cette
définition pour décider du sort des
trois anciens ministres juge et partie
pour les victimes
c'en est trop il demanda lisabeth guigou
d'intervenir c'est pour le gouvernement
leur pays
s'il étouffe l'affairé du sang contaminé
il trouvera définitivement que ces
discours sur l'indépendance de la
magistrature ne sont qu'un habillage
juridiquement la requête a peu de
chances d'aboutir d'abord elisabeth
guigou n'a pas le pouvoir de récuser un
magistrat ensuite rien n'interdit un
juge d'intervenir dans une affaire
similaire à celle qui l'instruit c'est
peut être choquant moralement mais ce
n'est pas contraire au droit
le ministère de la défense annonçait
aujourd'hui ses projets en matière de
restructuration des arsenaux public et
le redéploiement des forces armées 335
sites militaires vont être fermés 6000
postes supprimés mais au total la
professionnalisation des armées va
amener à la création de 68 600 emplois
civils et militaires la majorité des
régions sont gagnantes sauve ile de
france qui va perdre environ 14 cents
emplois ainsi que la normandie environ
700 emplois en moins pour certaines
villes
cette restructuration est un coup dur
c'est le cas de rochefort en
charente-maritime qui vivait en grande
partie par et pour la marine 2000 marins
et leurs familles pour 27 mille
habitants françois privat philippe reid
un appareil de l'aéronavale devenu
décoration de ronds-points à
rochefort-sur-mer ce symbole
appartiendra au passé dès le début du
xxième siècle lorsque près de deux
milles marins quitteront la ville 15 %
du territoire de la commune est
concernée par les informations qui
viennent de nous parvenir et qui
concerne le départ d'unités de la marine
nationale qui se situe différents
emplacements manche aujourd'hui je n'ai
aucune garantie et nous avons connu des
déboires considérable dans les années
précédentes avec des promesses qui n'ont
pas été tenues
inutile de vous dire que je suis
aujourd'hui extrêmement prudent et
j'exigerai que les compensations soient
affirmées
depuis son kane rochefort 27 mille
habitants se voit touchée de plein fouet
l'école des fourriers un effectif de 700
personnes déménagera vers cherbourg on y
forme principalement des agents
administratifs
c'est aussi la fin du centre école de
l'aéronautique navale
un millier de permanents ici
on assure l'instruction de futurs
mécaniciens en 1920 8
la marine a quitté affirmé l'arsenal en
1989 dans l'hôpital de la marine a été
fermée donc ceci c'est une mesure de
restructuration supplémentaires au xviie
siècle rochefort est né avec l'arrivée
de l'arsenal décidé par colbert sur la
charente
les bateaux ont disparu depuis longtemps
la corderie royale est devenu un musée
aujourd'hui dans les rues de la ville
tirés au cordeau les commerçants font
plutôt la grimace mais s'il ya quelque
chose qui remplace voir ce qu'ils vont
nous mettre à la loire si c'est un
départ pour un retour vont voir pouvoir
sait pas pourquoi c'est s'abattre oui ça
nous inquiète un peu plus et je prends
son alimentation qu'on habillement ils
s'inquiètent encore rochefort et la
marine la fin d'une histoire une école
de gendarmerie devrait venir s'installer
dans l'un des bâtiments vacants une
compensation pour ce qui concerne
maintenant le giat le groupement des
industries militaires les exportations
en régression amène le gouvernement à
réduire l'activité de plusieurs sites
des manifestations ont eu lieu
aujourd'hui un peu partout en france
damien thévenot michel levasseur
ils ont voulu tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
400 salariés de giat ce matin devant le
siège de l'entreprise à versailles
satory
un conseil d'administration doit adopter
officiellement le plan social
3600 suppressions d'emplois à la clé les
montées stop interrompre la séance vers
midi tout se fait dans le calme
les représentants faire des finances
s'éclipse discrètement mais les jeux
sont faits colère des syndicats ça
suffit de cette logique qui consiste à
116 baisser les commandes a sans cesse à
dépouiller l'entreprise
et puis après dire qu elle nous sort
effectué deux usines vont être rayés de
la carte d'ici à l'an 2000 salbris dans
le loir et cher et le mans rennes
fermera s'il n'y a pas de repreneur
dans les onze autres site de giat des
réductions d'effectifs entre 30 et 90 %
de suppressions de postes à roanne où
saint-etienne saint-etienne où 500
manifestants ont défilé ce matin
la loi est particulièrement touché 3
site giat dans ce département
pour le ministre de la défense alain
richard la compétitivité de l'entreprise
impose des sacrifices évident par les
dirigeants et salariés du lot
il reste un équilibre dont les salariés
ne veulent pas faire les frais il
envisage d'autres actions pour vendredi
jour du comité central d'entreprise le
plan social l'heure sera officiellement
présenté les employés de giat sont bien
décidés à ne pas baisser les armes
et puis on connaît déjà le volet
dépenses du budget de la france pour
1999 les ministères favoriser son celui
de la ville + 30 % de crédit
l'environnement + 15 % la justice + 5 %
en retrait la défense plus 1,9 pour cent
seulement équipements et transports
restent stables et matignon les services
du premier ministre qui annonce eu un
budget en baisse de 3 pouces l'actualité
internationale est d'abord la situation
financière de la russie est elle qu à
côté d'une mafia florissant des milliers
d'ouvriers dans tous les secteurs sont
impayés ou avec beaucoup de retard ainsi
depuis plusieurs semaines maintenant les
mineurs de charbon qui n'ont pas été
payés depuis plusieurs mois pour
certains occupent des tronçons des voies
ferrées celle du transsibérien par
exemple avec la ferme intention
d'obtenir satisfaction une sorte
d'énergie du désespoir reportage gilles
rabin franck
c'est gens disent il appelle le principe
pour principe est rien c'est la deuxième
fois en deux mois qu'ils bloquent la
voie ferrée qui traverse la russie
d'ouest en est cette fois ci ils se sont
mis d'accord avec la police il n'est ce
pas c'est les trains de voyageurs
il était déjà là la dernière fois un
atelier miller de fond 20 ans de mine
derrière lui je n'ai rien car je te le
dis honnêtement je n'ai rien on peut me
fusiller je ne mens pas je n'ai pu
m'acheter qu'une télé en battant de
travail je ne peux pas et pour pas cher
une soviétique yen japonais
l'histoire de nathalie c'est celle de
que ce qui bloque d'être en sibérie déjà
sous les communistes étaient mal payés
oui lessines ils ne sont plus payés du
tout alors comment se politise il
demande aujourd'hui la démission du
président j'arrive pas à comprendre
qu'un ministre vienne promettre comme en
mai dernier en public devant toute la
ville de payer les salaires
elles ne tiennent pas sa parole j'arrive
pas julie la fille d'un atelier venu
chercher son père pour le ramener à la
maison
il est malade dit elle et il doit se
reposer julie vient de terminer des
études de médecine
elle appartient déjà à un autre monde à
une autre époque au contraire d'un
atelier elle a compris depuis longtemps
que la mine qui n'est plus rentable est
condamné et qu une époque révolue
elle ne croit pas que les mineurs
obtiennent à j'aurai des missions de qui
que ce soit surtout pas celle de boris
eltsine
si on ne vire pas ce gouvernement ça ne
changera jamais vous excusez moi mais ce
sont tous des voleurs ou en nous je suis
plus inquiet pour mes enfants que pour
moi vous savez pour moi bientôt ça sera
la fin je vais mourir
mais pour je m'inquiète
avec toutes les dettes café ce
gouvernement mes enfants vont devoir
payer toute leur vie si vous irlande du
nord la tension monte dans la ville de
port d'aden où les protestants radicaux
ne veulent pas renoncer à leur marche
traditionnelle à travers un quartier
catholique avec les risques de violence
que cela compense est un test important
pour la crédibilité du nouveau
gouvernement autonome de l'irlande du
nord londres et tiennent la main le jeu
du chat et de la souris
depuis deux jours les militants de
l'ordre protestants d'orange multiplie
les barrages autour de portes d'armes
avant d'être systématiquement dispersées
par les forces de l'ordre les plus
radicaux d'entre eux continuent par
ailleurs de camper à l'entrée du
quartier catholique de la ville dont on
leur a refusé l'accès dimanche à
l'occasion de leur traditionnelle parade
les heures passent la tension monte et
le tout nouveau premier ministre de la
toute nouvelle assemblée régionale
s'inquiètent
nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre de
laisser les choses empiraient un
déchaînement de cette manière il y a
dans les deux camps loyalistes et
républicains des éléments perturbateurs
qui souhaitent exploiter cette crise
la nuit dernière des incidents à
répétition d'un nouveau secoué belfast
où 800 militaires vont être envoyés en
renfort le premier ministre britannique
tony blair recevra jeudi les
responsables orangistes mais sa marge de
manoeuvre est faible
malgré les accords de paix malgré le
référendum qui les a entérinées et
malgré l'assemblée régionale 106 les
faire appliquer l'irlande du nord se
retrouve à nouveau ce soir dans une
situation incertaine où les risques de
dérapages sont grands silvio berlusconi
condamné à deux ans et neuf mois de
prison ferme pour corruption par le
tribunal de milan il est condamné pour
sa gestion de son groupe industriel
fille nine west berlusconi va faire
appel at il dit
chaque année à pareille époque en ce
début des vacances la police chargée de
la surveillance des côtes en france
lance une série d'opéras
son coup de frein il s'agit comme son
nom l'indiqué de freiner l'ardeur des
pilotes occasionnels de bateaux à moteur
plus spécialement sur la côte d'azur
du côté de saint tropez 50
interpellations pour la seule journée
d'hier il ne faut pas confondre le golfe
avec le circuit du mans olivier théron
didier vaut quelque part dans le golfe
de saint tropez
le remorqueur d'intervention me roux est
le qg de l'opération coup de frein en
mer l'amiral durteste préfet maritime
vient lui même piloté la manoeuvre
première phase la conférence de presse
car le but c'est la prévention grâce à
l'impact médiatique de l'opération dans
la répression n'est qu'un moyen dans les
cas les plus graves
mais ce qui importe d'abord c'est
informer de manière à faire prendre
conscience de la réalité des risques de
prévenir ensuite contrôlé et bien sûr au
cours de ce contrôle lorsque les abus
manifestes sont pour taper de répéter
alors la préfecture maritime a mis les
moyens
cinq bâtiments sont en mer les affaires
maritimes les douanes la marina
gendarmerie participe au contrôle dans
la fameuse zone des 300 mètres où la
vitesse est limitée à 5 noeuds 9 km
heure un hélicoptère dauphin surveillent
la zone et repère les infractions sept
off shore est à plus de 50 noeuds il est
arraisonné un gendarme va être
hélitreuillé directement sur le bateau
les autres moyens d'intervention sont
plus conventionnel la marine doit
montrer qu'elle est là alors elle
multiplie les contrôles et rappelle les
consignes de sécurité
au total 104 bateaux ont été
interpellées sept pb pour vitesse
excessive ont été dressés et chaque fois
le même message distribués la liberté
des uns ne doit pas engagé la sécurité
des autres après la publication des
résultats du bac 98 on connaît désormais
le plus jeune ou plus exactement la plus
jeune bachelière de france
jessica une jeune monégasque de 13 ans
j'ai bien dû 13 ans qui entrera l'année
prochaine la faculté des sciences de
nice bat la liga j'ai 13 ans et demi
c'est son âge mais aussi sa moyenne au
bac et ça vaut bien une photo mention
assez bien pour jessica la plus jeune
lauréate de crue 98 elle n'a eu que neuf
en histoire-géo mais 16 en philo
le sujet était comment décider si un
acte est juste on jette parler de la
liberté qu'il fallait respecter la
liberté et de l'égalité aussi partant
pour aristote et du respect d'autrui
j'ai parlé de la morale kantienne et en
troisième partie j'ai dit qu'il y avait
quand même des hésitations de la morale
mais comme contre les gens je dis qu'en
fait il fallait se réaliser au mieux à
réaliser au mieux la justice malgré les
contingences qui existaient dès demain
sept jeunes monégasques eux s'inscrire à
la faculté des sciences de nice pour
étudier la biologie jouer dans la cour
des grands ne lui fait pas peur elle
prévoit un été mi sportif me studio de
l'équitation de natation du tennis et p
je regarde aussi la télé puis je suis en
train d'écrire un livre sur mes études
et sur le bac aussi et puis après ça
c'était vraiment des loisirs mais enfin
j'ai commencé à lire nos lignes de
spécialités bio pour l'année prochaine
en attendant jessica console et ses amis
convoqués au rattrapage
car si la valeur n'attend pas le nombre
des années tout vient à point à qui sait
attendre
nouveau record de la traversée de
l'atlantique entre new york et le cap
lizard christophe auguin et son équipage
ont mis 9 jours 22 heures 59 minutes 30
secondes précédentes
or était de 11 jours de match de ce soir
est très attendue à marseille entre le
brésil et les pays-bas mais l angoisse
pour tout supporter français
c'est demain demain à 21h au stade de
france à saint-denis les bleus
affronteront la croatie aujourd'hui aimé
jacquet a procédé aux derniers
entraînements yann lavoix andré germain
comme nous vous connaîtrez la
composition de l'équipe de france une
heure seulement demain avant le match
mais jacques est très heureux de la
performance de son milieu de terrain
face à l'italie reconduira sans doute 40
but pour empêcher les croates est trop
souvent en possession du ballon et
permettent aux bleus de faire le jeu
d'autant qu'ils seront favoris que ce
soit la croatie que ça soit l'allemagne
que ce soit demain le brésil que ce soit
lors nous sommes toujours des favoris
donc on ya longtemps qu'on a mis ce
costume et qu'on l'a assumé on a bien
assumé alors ça bien sûr que ça dérange
mais c'est comme ça il est opérationnel
depuis le 18 juin christophe dugarry se
soignait il est désormais guéri
sa titularisation de main paraît risqué
mais il pourrait bien jouer le rôle du
remplaçant joker lorsque l'on parle de
la croatie on parle inévitablement de
son potentiel offensif demain les
croates joueront sans doute plus en
retrait dans une position d'attenté mais
prêt à négocier chaque balle de contre
ils seront alors au moins cinq à se ruer
vers le but de barthez ils sont très
homogènes ils ont ils ont une équipe
très complète et qui peut je n'irai
travailler sur tout le front l'attaquent
pas seulement sur les côtés il prend son
cou avant de tirer un penalty davor
suker sera le client privilégié de main
de laurent blanc qui l'a affronté déjà
dans le championnat d'espagne
c'est un joueur qui est très malin qui
est très très futés donc bon il va
falloir essayer de le surveiller de très
près pas de trop près mais c'est en
force de l'éloigner le plus souvent
possible et le plus longtemps possible
de la surface de réparation car je crois
que c'est un joueur que dès qu'il arrive
dans cette zone de vérité est vraiment
présent pour pour les défenses même ses
coéquipiers disent de lui qu'il est fou
barthez fou de rire juste avant la
séance des tirs au but contre l'italie
lui explique que la décontraction et
source de concentration je suis
spectateur en même temps un acteur dont
le ballon est assez loin au sort du
match et en regardant dans les tribunes
ou regardant le bain ou en pensant à
autre chose donc ce qui me permet d'être
encore beaucoup plus concentré de me
fatigue nouveau nerveux nerveux demain
d'être moins fatigué alors essayer
demain de lui dire bonjour et peut-être
qu il vous répondra
quant aux croates et bien ils ont quitté
leur retraite de vittel cet après midi
sont arrivés à paris ce soir il
s'entraîne en ce moment même sur la
pelouse du stade de france à saint-denis
où nous retrouvons florent gautreau
florent oui bonjour bonsoir daniel en
fait ils viennent juste de terminer leur
entraînement et j'ai une petite surprise
pour vous puisque nous sommes avec le
sélectionneur de l'équipe de croatie
miroslav lazovic alors on va tout de
suite lui demander comment s'est passée
cette prise de contact avec le stade de
france que vous ne connaissez pas nous
sommes tous impressionnés par cette
manifestation qui est considéré comme le
plus beau monde
je suis tout à fait d'accord
malheureusement je ne peux pas donner
toutes les compliments pour la pelouse
parce qu'elle n'est pas des qualités qui
correspond je dois bilson aucune
scrupule qu'il aimerait bien tel and com
alors les croates ont quitté vittel vous
le savez cet après midi leur lieu de
villégiature ils vont maintenant logé à
chantilly ils resteront peut-être
jusqu'à dimanche s'ils battent les
français alors miroslav lazovic est ce
que vous êtes capable de refaire
l'exploit de l'allemagne et de battre
les français c'était difficile la d2 je
répète c'est pas pourquoi mais on voit
que français
évident non c'est celle que nous avons
notre chance c'est d'un football tout
est possible
une chose est certaine qu'ils ont fait
tout absolument tout dans l'esprit
sportif bien sûr pour se qualifier pour
une finale
lorsque mes joueurs et moi même nous
sommes confiants que c'est une occasion
qui c'était un pacha quatre années était
de 40 ans la classe il a jamais eu ni
privilèges et par new 8
aujourd'hui les gens parmi 4 est on est
on est tous très projet est confiant
pour le match demain alors il y avait
quelques alain décision concernant
l'équipe
crois tu je crois que finalement boban
va jouer on va demander au sélectionneur
sougueur boban tout le monde est là tout
le monde est prêt on l'a vu ça ne me
dérange pas que je vous donne ma
formation qui doit sortir demain
cela dit chabrol notre dernier on
s'estimait des stoppeurs oui c'est
bilici which des latéraux c'est stanic
ya remis au centre nc bat soldats côté
gauche à sandwich et bien voilà vous
avez vu il n'y a plus d' intox côté
croit ton à la sélection et la
composition de l'équipe 24 heures en
avance france croatie c'est demain ici
derrière moi au stade de france
on ne sait pas qui va gagner mais vous
vous êtes confiant si je peux m'exprimer
important car en faveur de france
voilà merci et avoue daniel si florent
résultats demain soir donc 21h dans un
instant la météo présentée par sophie
davant suivi donc du match brésil pays
bas en direct sur france 2 au vélodrome
de marseille commentée par pierre sled
et paul le guen je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée je n'en doute pas sur
nos prochaines bonsoir